[Música]
tras la salida de más de 260 militares
ucranianos de la planta de acceso total
en bario por rusia habla de una
rendición y ucrania insiste en que
fueron evacuados y en que esta operación
continuará para salvar la vida de los
combatientes con la caída del último
bastión de defensa el puerto de azufre
estaría completamente en manos rusas
tensión entre el reino unido en la unión
europea' por el protocolo para irlanda
del norte el gobierno británico anunció
un proyecto de ley para anular
unilateralmente aspectos del acuerdo
negociado como parte del break sheet si
no logra modificaciones con bruselas la
unión europea condenó la decisión y
advirtió que respondería
el gobierno de españa aprobó un
anteproyecto para reformar la ley de
salud sexual y reproductiva y de
interrupción del embarazo e impulsará
entre otros temas un permiso menstrual
retribuido una licencia de parto desde
la semana 39 y que las jóvenes de entre
16 y 17 años puedan abortar sin
consentimiento parental tenemos análisis
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz
comenzamos con información de la guerra
en ucrania más de 260 militares
ucranianos abandonaron la planta de
asostel en la ciudad de mariupol donde
resistieron durante semanas al asedio
ruso de esta forma se concretaría la
caída del puerto de ashod la versión de
los hechos varía entre ambas partes
mientras que moscú dice que los
efectivos se rindieron el gobierno
ucraniano insiste en que su salida hace
parte de un operativo de evacuación que
se viene realizando desde ayer y que
continuará para salvar la vida de los
soldados que para kiev ya cumplieron su
misión hasta ahora se confirma que los
combatientes fueron llevados por las
tropas del kremlin a zonas controladas
por separatistas pro rusos y la
viceministra de defensa de ucrania anna
amalia espera que sean intercambiados
por prisioneros de guerra por su parte
el presidente de la cámara baja del
parlamento ruso se refirió a ellos como
criminales de guerra que no deberían ser
canjeados sino juzgados esto dijo mallya
la diferencia sostenida por nuestros
defensores de mariupol no permitió que
el enemigo redistribuyera sus fuerzas
alrededor de 20.000 efectivos
el enemigo no pudo redistribuirse a
otras regiones y no fue capaz de
capturar rápidamente a sap origen
con
esta pericia y es que mario ball soportó
algunos de los peores episodios de la
guerra entre ellos el bombardeo a las
salas de maternidad la destrucción del
refugio de cientos de civiles y los
combates contra la planta de as hostal
veamos como era y lo que queda habrá
fue hogar de más de 400.000 personas
mariupol era una joya brillante de la
industria ucraniana el mayor centro de
comercio en el mar de azov su puerto y
su industria metalúrgica eran clave para
la economía del país hasta que el 24 de
febrero comenzó la invasión rusa a
principios de marzo los bombardeos se
habían convertido los complejos de
apartamentos de mariupol en torres de
escombros para el 7 de marzo las tropas
rusas habían rodeado la ciudad cortaron
el acceso a alimentos la electricidad
los suministros médicos y la mayoría de
rutas de escape para los civiles
entonces el 9 de marzo los proyectiles
alcanzaron un hospital de maternidad de
la ciudad las imágenes de madres
embarazadas heridas conmocionaron al
mundo pero a mariupol todavía le
esperaban más horrores el 16 de marzo
atacaron el teatro del tejado rojo
símbolo de la creciente prosperidad y
cultura de la ciudad más de 1000 civiles
se habían refugiado en su interior tras
no poder escapar de la localidad
asediada se cree que hasta 600 personas
entre muchos niños perecieron según
testimonios de supervivientes dados a la
agencia de noticias ap el bloqueo de
mariupol pasará a la historia de la
responsabilidad por los crímenes de
guerra es un terror que se recordara
durante siglos
cuando las fuerzas rusas tomaron la
mayor parte de la ciudad el único
reducto que quedaba era su principal
fábrica de acero la planta de aceptar
sus kilométricos pasillos subterráneos y
búnkeres proporcionaron una protección
ideal durante más de dos meses y medio
los soldados ucranianos consiguieron
junto a los civiles resistir allí con su
salida es el último reducto de mario
porque cambia de manos a sólo unos 600
kilómetros de la frontera rusa mariupol
ha sufrido un fuerte asedio debido a su
ubicación estratégica la ciudad es una
vía de paso o enlace terrestre entre los
territorios respaldados por rusia en el
este y crimea en el sur y tomar el
control de su industria metalúrgica y
del mar de azov proporcionaría a moscú
una victoria simbólica y económica a
costa de decenas de miles de vidas
cambiamos de tema el gobierno de londres
aseguró que en las próximas semanas
pretende hacer algunos cambios
unilaterales en el protocolo de irlanda
del norte que tras el break sheet buscó
establecer normas comerciales que
evitarán el retorno de una frontera
física entre las dos irlandas la
secretaria de exteriores británica
listos insistió en que siguen abiertos
al diálogo con el bloque pero bruselas
dijo que su respuesta sería contundente
dando un giro de 180 grados respecto a
lo acordado en 2019 el gobierno de reino
unido prepara una nueva ley para alterar
el protocolo de irlanda del norte
forster maestra preferencia continúa
siendo una solución negociada con la
unión europea y en paralelo a la
legislación que presentamos seguimos
abiertos a futuras conversaciones si
podemos conseguir el mismo resultado
mediante un acuerdo negoció
el protocolo de irlanda del norte es el
principal motivo de parálisis política
en el territorio norirlandés y una
fuente de tensiones desde que entró en
vigor en 2021 creo que es el protocolo
de irlanda del norte forma parte de los
acuerdos del brics y el mar de
separación entre londres y bruselas con
la salida del reino unido- de la unión
europea había que establecer una
frontera para los controles migratorios
y aduaneros de entrada al mercado único
europeo irlanda del norte es la única
parte del reino unido- que limita por
tierra con la unión europea comparte
fronteras con la república de irlanda
sin embargo la reimposición de nuevas
barreras entre las dos irlandas hacía
temer el resurgimiento de la histórica
violencia entre grupos republicanos y
unionistas de las últimas décadas así
que se decidió establecer los controles
en el mar de irlanda entre territorio
norirlandés y el resto del territorio
británico estas disposiciones conforman
el protocolo de irlanda del norte y ha
recogido por el derecho internacional
pero la solución está lejos de ser
definitiva el partido unionista
democrático de irlanda del norte que
quiere permanecer unido a londres
argumenta que la frontera en el mar de
irlanda socava la posición de irlanda
del norte en el reino unido- por lo que
rechazan aliarse con el sinn fein para
formar el gobierno regional hasta que se
resuelvan las diferencias sobre el
protocolo el sinn fein que quiere con la
república de irlanda y defiende el
protocolo ganó las elecciones de este
mayo pero necesita el apoyo de partidos
unionistas para liderar el ejecutivo por
otro lado downing street- critica la
unión europea por ceñirse al protocolo
de forma inflexible bruselas asegura que
responderá firmemente si londres
continúa adelante con su cambio que
considera una violación flagrante de un
acuerdo internacional vamos a españa que
se encamina a reformar y ampliar la ley
de salud sexual y reproductiva y de
interrupción del embarazo el consejo de
ministros aprobó el anteproyecto que
sería votado por el gabinete la próxima
semana entre los puntos clave del texto
se encuentran permitir que las mujeres
desde los 16 años puedan interrumpir su
embarazo sin el consentimiento de sus
padres una incapacidad médica retribuida
por el estado para mujeres con fuertes
dolores menstruales que el seguro de
salud proporcione la píldora
anticonceptiva y un permiso de
maternidad adelantado además la
gestación subrogada quedaría
explícitamente descrita como violatoria
de los derechos humanos para el análisis
nos conectamos en barcelona españa-- con
marta wood que gallego y es abogada
experta en derecho género y salud señora
bus que es bienvenido bienvenida a
france24 una de las medidas más
difundidas y polémicas es el permiso de
baja por dolores menstruales será
posible que se mantenga este punto que
representaría este permiso para la lucha
feminista
hola buenas noches y gracias por el
espacio en realidad de este proyecto de
reforma de ley incluye cosas o digamos
que regula cosas que ya están sucediendo
y que sencillamente les da una cabida a
nivel legislativo es decir por ejemplo
asociaciones de salud que tienen que ver
con endometriosis o problemas
menstruales sus usuarias o personas que
tienen esta situación ya están
recurriendo a bajas médicas lo que pasa
que no tiene una cavidad específica y al
no estar reguladas pues por ejemplo son
son bajas que no se cobran no entonces
lo que la ley intenta es dar cabida y
regularizar esta situación yo entiendo o
espero que sí que se pueda mantener
porque está previsto para incapacidades
temporales de reglas no de cualquier
regla sino de reglas dolorosas e
incapacitantes ahora la maternidad es
ampliamente abordada desde las
posibilidades del aborto pasando por los
permisos de maternidad e incluso
rechazando fuertemente la gestación
subrogada qué opina del texto en estos
apartes
en realidad por ejemplo en relación al
aborto lo que implica es volver a la
situación anterior a la reforma que
realizó el pp de acuerdo entonces
básicamente elimina los tres días de
pensárselo en relación al aborto la
obligación de información previa es
decir existe la opción es opcional pero
no es obligatoria e incluye que puedas
tener un permiso para recuperarte
después una interrupción del embarazo ya
sea voluntaria o fortuita
asegura que puedas tener como las dos
opciones tarmac o lógicas o quirúrgicas
en los centros y en relación a la edad
de acceder a el aborto efectivamente
vuelve a la situación anterior a la
última reforma porque porque esto está
pensado sobre todo para mujeres chicas
en situación de especial vulnerabilidad
que pueden tener represalias en su
entorno en caso de que se conozca la
situación de embarazo y en relación al
el permiso desde la semana 39 preparto
me parece interesante especialmente en
un contexto en que en españa sobre todo
las mutuas han endurecido los requisitos
para acceder a bajas o permisos justo
antes de dar con lo cual muchas mujeres
tienen que acudir a bajas pues por dolor
de espalda y otro tipo de circunstancias
y de nuevo está le intenta dar cabida a
esto
marta busquets gallego abogada experta
en derecho generalizados muchas gracias
por acompañarnos para analizar este tema
aquí en france 24
y vamos a eeuu al presidente joe biden
rindió homenaje a las 10 personas
afroamericanas asesinadas en un
supermercado en búfalo el sábado uno más
en un violento historial de ataques
masivos con estas características veamos
los ataques por motivos raciales
aumentaron en eeuu en la última década
la pandemia de koi 19 por ejemplo
alimentó la violencia contra la
comunidad asiática en marzo de 2021 un
hombre de 21 años atacó tres salones de
masaje en atlanta dejando ocho muertos
entre ellos seis mujeres de origen
asiático los activistas afirman que las
declaraciones de donald trump presidente
durante el estallido de la crisis
sanitaria amplificaron el odio
cuando el presidente de eeuu llama al
coronavirus virus de china con club es
un insulto para todos nosotros los
asiáticos se están culpando de un virus
que no tiene nada que ver con nosotros
en agosto de 2019 un hombre que se
declaró un militante de extrema derecha
desató una masacre de 23 personas en un
supermercado en texas le dijo a la
policía que quería matar a todos los
mexicanos posibles un año antes en 2018
un supremacista blanco irrumpió en una
sinagoga de pittsburgh y mató a tiros a
11 personas en el que se convirtió en el
ataque antisemita más mortífero de la
historia del país
está la escena del crimen más horrible
que he visto en 23 años en el fbi los
miembros de la sinagoga árbol de la vida
que realizaban un servicio pacífico en
su lugar de culto fueron brutalmente
asesinados por un hombre armado que los
tenía como objetivo simplemente por su
fe y en junio de 2015 un hombre de 21
años abrió fuego en una iglesia en
carolina del sur apagando la vida de
nueve afroamericanos en los últimos años
la llamada teoría del gran reemplazo ha
ido ganando terreno en eeuu la teoría
racista de la conspiración afirma que la
población blanca sería sustituida
gradualmente hasta su extinción por
inmigrantes no blancos
investigadores de los tiroteos masivos
descubrieron que ha inspirado a varios
autores de ataques hasta que este
informativo gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]